Jason Locke and flora of CBS sports CBS
NFL insider everybody thinks it's a done
deal
Connor Murray to the Cardinals do you
agree with that Jason I think he's gonna
be the first overall pick I not going to
say that I absolutely positively know
that they will make that pick you know I
still think that a trade is always a
possibility but no doubt calamari is the
story of this of this combine it all he
did is stand there and get measured and
it's crazy I mean someone asked me
earlier today like you know you what's
the story this combine what's different
from from this combine about others
you've covered I'm like I never can
recall the potential first overall pick
being a kid who Scouts basically didn't
even talk to in you know October as they
went through his school because he
wasn't here as a draftable commodity
because by the time were at the combine
he's gonna be in like Peoria Arizona or
whatever you know in with the age minor
leaguers getting ready to play in the
California State League like it's yeah
this is a new one but it's happening
well I mean we're watching him while you
were going through your first statement
there Jason watching video and I'll
describe the radio audience of him
running around to avoid the rush and
then making spectacular plays with his
legs and we all know he can make some
incredible throws as well but you hit on
something there the evaluation of Kyle
Emery I mean what did you hear about the
evaluation of him at the combine not the
eye and the sky stuff the stuff when
they could look at him in the eye and
talk about it with him or anything else
going down to any testing that he did in
fact undergo because as you point out
Scouts didn't even take a look at him
they were assuming he's going to
baseball they assumed at five nine or
whatever he was that they weren't gonna
take him anyway and then his tape has
made everybody feel differently yeah I
mean you know he obviously started
meeting with teams and interviewing with
teams I didn't hear anything drastic one
way or the other you know as teams put
him on the board they're gonna have to
be oh and we're saying all this but like
the reality is it's probably going to
one team right and they already know he
does exactly
you think they need him to know and like
so I almost feel like I'm wasting my
breath here because but teams still have
to do all their evaluations so yes he'll
have a pro day and yes we'll make
personal visits and people will put him
on the board and there'll be varying
degrees of comfort about if he could do
what we need him to do and how much
would we have to do to meet him with
what he can do and would have you know
how does our our protection shape up and
is he going to have the kind of time and
space that he got in Oklahoma where at
times their line was met against boys so
there's all these different mental
calculations that go into it and and but
at the end of the day like I think we
all know what Kliff Kingsbury probably
stinks of them right is it his call is
it his call Jason I mean that's the
interesting aspect of this too is you've
got an organization that just one and
done their coach a general manager or
general manager who had off the I guess
outside of the building issues and an
owner that is no doubt antsy to get some
sort of buzz going on with the franchise
despite Josh Rosen can't really evaluate
how good he is based on let me get this
right 52 sacks allowed last year by an
offensive line so what about the
intrigue with Arizona here playing into
all this well at this point you would
have to believe that Steve time and
Kliff Kingsbury are joined at the hip
with this I mean you can't tell me that
as they're talking to Kliff Kingsbury
and through that interview process and
you know going out with the owner and
you know having 5-hour dinners and all
that that the prospect of this didn't
come up so if this is what they end up
doing taking you know a baby quarterback
first overall to replace the baby
quarterback they just took 10th overall
what not even 11 months ago you would
have to assume that that was part of a
master plan and part of the reason why
when you have the first overall pick you
know you can control the draft and and
if this guy thinks this coach thinks
enough about Kyler Murray and what he
can do to help this system translate in
the pro game the
you would have to assume that the
Genesis and origins of that came then
but to your larger point about what's
going on in that organization for
anybody to try to judge Josh Rosen on
what he was thrust into where the dude
who picked him is getting an extreme DUI
and literally is like in jail and then
suspended while you're getting your feet
wet and he's Rosen's not the one who
gave what 25 odd million dollars
guaranteed to Glennon and Bradford and
he's not the one who put together that
Frankenstein staff and fired
you know Mike McCoy like six weeks into
the season right and he's not the one
who then parted with that staff that the
Cardinals pretty much put together
because it's not like Steve Wilkes came
in there with a ton of his own ideas and
like a group of 15 guys you know who
were coming with me it's like he was
putting the band back together like
Gibbs 2.0 or Gruden to point you know
2.0 now in Oakland and then the
quarterback has to play before he's
ready and then you don't know how to use
the running back anymore and he's got
nobody to throw to other than Larry
Fitzgerald and the offensive line is
getting eaten alive like I think if they
do what everybody thinks they're gonna
do now is take this other quarterback
first overall it begs the question why
did you do what you did last year like
what the bleep was that was it a move of
any conviction whatsoever or was it just
that like you know one of the three DS
quarterbacks we're gonna go and like you
know the top seven or eight and then we
got to get to 10 because Oakland was
open for business
to get whichever one of those four you
know whichever one isn't one of the
first three and also isn't Lamar Jackson
like is that is that what that was
because if that's not what that was then
it would be really easy to put the
Cuyler Murray stuff to bed right now and
just go ahead and trade off that pick or
whatever and start throwing your arms
around Josh Rosen man I mean does Maury
have it to handle so these are but you
put the Jason lock and four here in the
Rich Eisen show then you put every egg
in the calamari basket and you're hoping
that he is he is the next sliced bread
guy because that the tape that the tape
that we saw on at Oklahoma emerges in
the NFL and you're also selling
incredibly low again on a kid you just
moved up to take first overall and like
don't try to that wasn't a Steve you
know like don't try to tell me like the
offensive coordinator who you fired like
I don't know 20 quarters into the season
you know like he was no I mean that was
an organizational move I mean that's
that's been well and Steve time there's
no other way to put it so then I guess
in a way they're they're lucky that that
carla marie comes in and if he is that
special he could change this whole thing
around really quick or they just I've
never seen the number of people that
just swear this is absolutely going to
happen coming out of a combine that the
next few weeks I'm not saying that but I
I hear plenty of people who are and
people coaches and executives with other
teams are utterly convinced of it and if
they if that's the case and it works
who cares of course the case and they
help send the flames of Kyla Marie to
the point where two or three other teams
feel like they got to go to one to get a
quarterback but good for them you know
and they turn it into a Bosco trade to
fill the 9,000 holes in their Swiss
cheese roster but if it's not either of
the to take it in conjunction with
everything that's kind of going on there
since the demise of the Bruce Arians era
and even before that I mean you know
paying paying Carson Palmer when they
didn't have to probably waiting a year
too long to make the move for the
quarterback again unless they trade out
of you know one and build around Josh
Rosen yeah you look at all that in its
totality and you say there's a reason
some teams winning this league and a
reason some you know some don't
Jason lock and for a few more minutes
left with him the Antonio Brown stuff
where does that stand new league ear
opens next week does he go somewhere
yeah he does I can tell you this they
won't dump them just to dump them to get
around the roster bonus I mean at this
point they're all in I'll take the
twenty million dollar cap hit and having
a Antonio Brown be something of a sunk
cost so they're not gonna just ship them
four or five you know oh let's just get
rid of them before you know before we
have to pay him any roster bonus or
anything like that that won't be a
factor
his actions haven't helped them you know
it's it's it's taken a mark
a lot of people thought would form in a
fairly robust manner and it turned it
into sort of a you know a dribble here
and a dribble there but I still think
they can get better than a third-round
pick for him I think didn't get a
second-round pick for him
Oakland's got a ton of picks you know
the Eagles have been monitoring that
situation and there's not too many deals
made in this league that Howie Roseman
doesn't at least consider making himself
for players of this caliber you know
Washington maybe III here there's a
split in that organization about you
know whether this really makes sense for
them right now but ultimately if Dan
Schneider gets his way any and he does I
don't think you could completely rule
them out by any stretch but yeah it's
not it's it's not what it could have
been had he handled this differently and
frankly had they handled it differently
so Foles is to Jacksonville that's the
scuttlebutt coming out of the combine is
that is that as done a deal as
everyone's referring to I mean it's it's
like calamari is gonna be Arizona's guy
and Foles is gonna be Jacksonville's guy
that's basically the two certainties
along with death and taxes coming out of
of the combine yes sure
I almost didn't I almost DNF I would
write it in sharpie rich I would write
it in pencil but there's you know
there's some dynamics inside that
organization at play and he's not you
know the only game in town there there
is a draft coming up and and while maybe
they'd have to move up to get one of the
top two it wouldn't have to move up all
that much and Teddy Bridgewater last I
checked he's still 26 years old and you
know has won playoff games in the league
and you know if you you've got the Tyrod
Taylor out there who's been to the
playoffs himself so it's not as if you
know it's Nick Foles or bust and I don't
know of an agreement that's in place yet
and so until that happens I would say
you know stay tuned Tom Coughlin is is
clearly in charge there there were
people in that building who I was told
felt like a trade for Flacco might make
sense but Tom Coughlin you know wasn't
one of them
and that didn't happen there's a bit of
a split on this right now and and I
think Coughlin who's empowered there you
know I mean he again clearly is running
things I think him maybe some of these
one of these young quarterbacks
particularly Ohio State he can fall in
love with and and and be cool with that
other people there know if they don't
win more games they're definitely going
to be out the building after the
collapse of last season so you know and
at what price point Nick Foles as well
you know is it hey Nick take it or leave
it man we're gonna give you a base of 15
and you can earn another five and
incentives if you do what you did in
Philly you know I don't know that 25
million dollar figure that was out there
on the franchise tag I don't know if
that's factors in for Nick Foles yeah
and then last one for you Lev Bell
that's the one thing that I was hearing
is look out for the Colts with their
monster cap room that that he might wind
up there in Indianapolis that's what I
heard when I left the building what do
you think I don't think that's what
Chris Ballard does I I think the culture
he's trying to build there and the
little engine that could and knowing
what he has in Andrew Luck and they ran
the ball you know I'm not saying Marlin
Mack is letting on bail but they they
liked the some of the different types of
backs they have and the different ways
they can skin that cat I hear much more
about them on wide receivers than I do
about levy on bail and certainly if they
can get their hands on pass rush that's
a priority and defense more than
anything else is I think if he's making
a big ticket item like that I think it's
a receiver and or defense of which which
receiver be a corner which we know or a
pass rusher with I think the Raiders
maybe with Le'Veon Bell you know I think
Jets have you know a lot of talk about
the Jets but but what I've heard lately
is that the Jets would be content to go
with Tevin Coleman if this lets levy on
bills money goes anywhere near where he
wants it to go I personally don't think
it gets to that stratosphere and what
about what receivers are
red hot do you think that the Colts
would be on or others would be on
I think the Colts will be looking at an
outside receiver like Tyrell Williams
from the Chargers who I hear Oakland is
very hot on as well and then all these
slot guys are going to do well it's just
which flavor do you like and at which
price point you know you've got you've
got Golden Tate
you've got the kid Humphreys in Tampa
who really started emerging in that
offense the last year so you've got cold
Beasley who you know he's 30 which is an
ideal but he's also been really really
productive in an offense that didn't
utilize him the way one like you know
New England might so you know did I
mention Golden Tate I mean there's
there's a bunch of guys who primarily do
their work in the slot I think you were
all gonna fall somewhere between you
know nine ish a year all the way up to
in the case of Tyra Williams an outside
guy I would not be shocked if he was in
the 1213 billion dollar-a-year region
lock good to see an Indianapolis and you
know best of luck to balance life and
business over the next two very busy
yeah we'll get there eventually I don't
know about the next two weeks but thank
you sir good seeing you as well you bet
that's Jason Malkin for my old NFL
Network compadre the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience